hi my name is Nina today we're gonna
make quinoa salad first I need to get
one cup of quinoa this is the key word
that I thought from costco they always
have extraction on the back add 2 cups
water to one cup quinoa it says bring to
boil but I'm going to use the other rice
cooker so first I need to wash the king
I 1 cup of quinoa I need to read the
King offers
in 2 cup of water too okay I'm going to
pour into this rice cooker ok so I'm
going to let it cook they don't have a
setting for quinoa so you can either use
brown rice or white white rice last time
I use brown rice but took so long to
cook about like 50 minutes right now I'm
gonna try the water I see how long they
will cook I forgot to mention what I
what the ingredient that I use for king
was salad I used kidney beans you can
use black bean but I bought kidney beans
you have to let it soak overnight I
didn't use the whole bag I use like
quarter one third of the bag this was
soaked from last night and I also use
cherry tomatoes I like I found this one
from Costco has a few different colors
so and then also use arugula it's mixed
with spinach to and cilantro I like to
add red pepper and of course out ground
pepper and then olive oil that's it so
right now I'm gonna make the beans
and pour it into here I'm going to cook
for half an hour so while waiting for
the bees and quinoa to cook I'm gonna
prepare to cut the cherry tomato and the
cilantro ok so I'm going to cut some
stamps off don't make the stems I mean
eat the leaves the preparation tips it's
pouring just chopping up the cilantros
into small pieces so you take a cherry
tomato then place the knife on the top
and use your index and thumb to hold the
tomato in the middle of the knife and
cut it in half so it's boiling the
puppies border I'm going to stir the pot
we have to cook for half and half an
hour
I like more tomatoes in my quinoa salad
so I'm putting more hmmm i could smell
the quinoa right now i'm not sure if you
could smell it so I'm done all the
cutting so we have about another 20
minutes for the beans maybe wish your
paws wait for the means have nothing to
do right now but I don't remember why i
always put the Sultan in the water to
boil first will boil faster second acts
of flavor into whatever you're cooking
Cheers so the beans are done and the key
was cook it took probably half an hour
to cook I'm gonna unplug it let it cool
open it to see all the steam is coming
out and the beans are done I'm gonna
turn off the stove and I say I'm gonna
put into a bowl and rinse it off rinse
the beans I want to rinse the beans so
it's co and it's easy to make
scoop it off first
you can coop the beans by leaving in the
fridge overnight or you can just rinse
it off with the cold water but if you're
going to live in the fridge make sure
you have to rinse the beans every day
y'all's gonna get very smelly okay this
is done I'm going to put the beans in
the bow the bow has the the cherry
tomato dads are already chopped up gonna
transfer the quinoa / split up hot so
Kippy it's actually cooked very well
with the rice cooker so to open the
south is some spinach and arugula you
could if you read the label it says open
here open here not open like this from
the corner like someone else that's what
this guy does it makes it you to stay
okay
maybe through 22 handful for Archie
three handfuls okay
mix it together so olive oil about 3
tablespoons but I just do it like this
so therefore so made to taste depends
how salty you like it 7likes pretty
salty food so mix it hot pepper same
thing depends how spicy you like your
salad TV heaven doesn't really like
spicy food so I'm not going to put that
much and then I'm going to add the
cilantro cilantro that I cut up earlier
okay and then mix it well oh one more
thing you have the attitude to the salad
is deep you can use the fresh lemons or
but we don't have fresh lemon so we're
going to use the the lemon juice instead
about 1 1 teaspoon maybe but you don't
have to but if you want you could it's
going to add little bit maybe like to
pinch okay
hmm let's see it looks very pretty Missy
then do need more salt no yeah the
tomatoes awesome we like to be healthy
King was healthy we use quinoa instead
of rice white rice it's not that healthy
for you it's white white white foods
white anything is not healthy for you
white bread white cereals I don't know
what else there is that's why why am I
on this show I'm just I'm just you talk
i'm just eating that's my role thank you
for watching believe hi is it up oh he
didn't tell me what's so funny we're
gonna have lit up what little bit more
olive oil oh no more you gonna have some
no let me know oh I'm full have a little
bit citrus they can we don't forget to
check out my newsletter click the link
below hi i'm jason j reyez fonseka of
ra's online com and i want to say Evan
Carmichael's newsletter is consistent
fun inspiring and it's deep only
newsletter i prioritize and look forward
to period